lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar un poco en lo que los números
representan realmente digamos que tengo
el número 25
25 que representa este número realmente
bueno el 5 está en la posición de las
unidades y representa 5 unidades y este
2 está en la posición de las decenas de
escenas y este está en la posición de
las unidades y aquí escribo unidades
pero que queremos decir con esto bueno
vamos a ver otra manera de escribir este
número este 2 representa dos decenas que
lo podemos escribir como dos decenas
+ 5 unidades 5 unidades
y qué significa dos decenas cuando
pensamos en dos decenas podemos pensar
en dos grupos de diez cosas bloques de
diez cosas y voy a usar estos bloques
para representar estas dos decenas lo
copió y tengo una decena
y dos decenas
aquí tengo representadas dos escenas que
es lo mismo que 20 cosas más 5 unidades
y las unidades las tenemos representadas
aquí con una barra vertical y 5 unidades
se vería como sigue una
es
y 5
estas son distintas maneras de
representar la misma cantidad 25 es lo
mismo que dos decenas y cinco unidades
el 2 está en la posición de las decenas
y el 5 en la posición de las unidades
así que dos decenas más cinco unidades
también lo podemos visualizar como dos
grupos de diez y cinco unidades y estos
dos grupos de diez son igual a veinte y
este de aquí es igual a cinco
todas estas son distintas formas de
representar el número 25 aquí tenemos
dos decenas y cinco unidades que lo
podemos escribir como dos decenas más
cinco unidades y también podemos
escribir este 25 25 como este 2 es dos
decenas así que es veinte más cinco
unidades